let me ask you a difficult question is
there anything in life that you love so
much that you'd be willing to give up
your Iman in order to achieve it I mean
for example if I were to give you a
villa a beautiful spouse and 100 million
dollars in cash would you give up your
faith in order to achieve this never
right but what if you are dying from
thirst and hunger would you exchange
your religion for food and drink
probably not probably not you'd rather
prefer to die in hunger than losing your
this is how much we value our faith it's
brothers and sisters let me introduce
you to Norway this is a European country
where the vast majority of the people
have abundant their belief in a religion
there are two hundred thousand Muslims
of a population of about 5 million and
most of these 200 000 Muslims have no
idea how to explain Islam to their
non-muslim friends and neighbors but
that needs to change Allah sent his
Messengers to call people to Eternal
success and that is why Muslims in
Norway are now establishing a Masjid and
dawah Center to enhance the Norwegian
Tower but they cannot do it alone we
need to support them if you donate to
this cause you will inshallah reap the
rewards of thousands of Muslims getting
close to Allah and many of those will
become Dwight and invite to Islam you
sharing the reward for all of these
shahadas and Good Deeds that come
inshallah so click the link and donate
now and share the video for extra
Rewards
foreign
[Music]